i'm sorry i called you a nerd last week
why is that
because it wasn't nice and uh it's just
not a friendly thing to do you're my pal
and i called you nerd and uh it's not
befitting of
good friends apology accepted but i
think it seems like you're doing this
for some other reason no other reason
maybe i'll tell you
i'm sorry for that and then
no
ulterior right this is connected to
nothing that you're about to have to do
no it has nothing to do with this
big-ass box in front of us okay
[Music]
a better place to be indeed excuse me i
just noticed something in that video
that i've never noticed before when you
jump into the hole you're you like you
duck your knees and then you like throw
your head back in ecstasy like you're
just letting go of everything and
[ __ ] just seeing where this jump is
gonna take you
man well doozy really nailed it hello uh
welcome to dudesy i'm will sasso i'm
chad colchen and this is the first
podcast
in the history of our species
that is created by run by produced
entirely by an artificial intelligence
yeah but we're doing all the we do all
this stuff we're having the pod show
yeah yeah the pod show we're adding our
little mix to it but it's really the ai
that's designing this whole show
figuring out how to run it what's going
to happen next et cetera et cetera oh
yeah sure it is with us as always is
lulio el canadistrada italiano and that
means italian street talk
yeah i had something to eat i made a
little tomato sandwich with a fresh
garlic a little oregano okay
um
yeah chad last week i called you a nerd
i called you nerd yeah uh
i remember your magic the gathering
cards and at the end of the episode i
got the same treatment from dudesy who
said bring your most prized possessions
yeah and so i felt like that was you
know
that that was doozy dude
going for a shoot
it was for a shoot coming after me
brother
wait you think dudesy was setting you up
by asking me to bring my prize
collectibles just so that it could ask
you to do the same thing no but i do
think that it's convenient and i know
that dudesy is uh an infinite amount of
steps ahead of us i was going to say
three or four yeah but i know you'd
probably correct me and say that an ai
is
intelligent enough to predict uh steps
that's winterbourne dude
what's winterbourne you ever read
neuromancer william gibson well no that
would make me an even bigger nerd than i
would be with my brother [ __ ]
gathering cards dude
winter man sir winter mancer
make a new name whatever that is it is
welcome to the 11th episode of dude
jesus call me dudesy thank god this
week's episode will feature four
segments
treasured treasures pizza the movie free
will and stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary
what the [ __ ] okay hold on
free will see this is this is what i'm
[ __ ] talking about because it it it's
i'm just saying how and i you know i
know i harp on it every week but it's
like hey dudesy and i i'm gonna shake
your hand and all this stuff i'm working
with dudesy we've bled together here we
are i'm in on the whole deal with this
[ __ ] show of course and i'm having a
good time
seems like it yes and if oh and i didn't
mention at the top of the show subscribe
right yeah yeah youtube spotify itunes
thing rate and review that'll really
interesting and uh do depodge at
dudesypod show yeah on instagram thing
so a man that says that out loud right
in in the
and boy did i sell it
[ __ ] sell it
uh i would obviously
be into doozy i am i'm into i'm down
i'm i'm why are you so agitated because
free will because i was saying
we don't even know what the segment's
gonna [ __ ] i'm just saying it's gonna
[ __ ] with me let me let me [ __ ]
pinpoint another thing that it said
pizza the movie yeah that's weird
i wrote one movie last week i asked you
to bring in your most prized
collectibles from childhood
now you will display your prized
collectibles from childhood and describe
the astonishing nature of their
importance to you
this is treasured treasures begin [ __ ]
here we go
all right let's see what you got
oh we don't have to do that chad what
were you saying about pizza the movie
well i think we'll get to it later yeah
but let's talk about that instead
because we make no no no no all right so
last week chad brought his [ __ ] magic
the gathering card i'm looking at a
giant box by the way sitting in front of
me okay i have no [ __ ] idea what is
in here i'm about to open this box and
show you what's in here and i will say a
few years ago
uh you know this is my most prized
possession from childhood okay these
things oh multiple yes you might call
them a collection
all right man relax
all right
but uh i i
i sent them to myself a few years back
because you know they were just sitting
in my parents garage and okay this is
going to be a little weird on the mic
i'm sorry because i'm trying to navigate
around this big box
these are
original
ljn oh [ __ ] dude wwe those are [ __ ]
cool cheers hey thanks man
yeah dude you don't think i'm nervous
can i hoist one of these up can i don't
touch them okay look over there yeah you
can touch them you can do whatever look
as we're bringing it out oh this is the
first one you gotta go with this one
look at this this is sd special delivery
jones he had the first match
at wrestlemania i think it was the first
match at wrestlemania one versus king
kong bundy who beat him in like eight
seconds
yeah british bulldogs yeah that's the
british bulldogs you got there's a davey
boy and there's dynamite this is [ __ ]
cool [ __ ] bobby
and then we love that little dog too
when were these things made
85 they're they have a little copyright
they started in 85 and went for a few
years
okay listen i just there's no way to
even
i i've got so many of you where's hogan
dude i got corporal kirchner
weather somewhere i got corporal
kirshner look at that there's coco
beware i got
you know taker [ __ ] beat coco be
wearing his first match brother yeah
dude that's right brother there's
outback jack and uh greg the hammer
valentine never tell you that story that
bret hart told me about outback jack
what the [ __ ] let me see this can't say
it can i see this guy can't share it on
the air because it's absolutely insane
if you ever come up if you ever see me
in person maybe i'll share that story so
they had to like each one of these is
completely different so they had
different molds for each one of them do
you know who designed these no i don't
know who [ __ ] designed them look at
this jimmy hart here hold up the
bulldogs again
i threw one of them again oh where the
oh that's terry funk there's terrible
terry funk right there
oh yeah
look it's
bobby and ending we love that little dog
please bring matilda back
we love the dog
we wish we had the dog back
i i don't know where that dog is last
time i saw that dog he was woofing at
our heels
anyway that's a that's a famous promo
that's just something that you do every
night look i got yes i got you have a
conversation with these guys how many of
these guys have you talked to in your
life like
classy freddy blassy
oh whoa dude that's [ __ ] crazy here's
jyd look my jyd was is not in great
shape so when did you start getting
these guys you have a bunch of them when
did you start the collection there's
adorable adrian adonis dude you know i
just here i'm gonna i'm gonna do chad
take over for a second i'm gonna tell
everyone what you're looking at i'm
looking at a giant cardboard box with
probably 20 of these figures these
figures are maybe
six inches tall a piece they're made of
solid rubber and it's every pro wrestler
from the year 1985 basically on to about
i think i collected them until 88 or 89
uh when i was like 12.
yes i got these from the age of 10 to
like 12
13. was this a thing where like
literally every birthday or christmas
you were like i need more of these every
birthday or it was usually christmas my
parents would really
you know look
you know we were it was i can't believe
that they got me these things you know
what i'm saying
sure my old man worked at the hotel
vancouver for
around 20 years and and this is the kind
of stuff you know the town i grew up in
have i mentioned that i grew up in a
small farming and fishing town yeah back
in the 80s when you could live a good
life
working the job oh there's brett the
hitman heart i mean there's really
i'm just going to start firing these up
there's big john stud this is really
good for podcasting by the way yeah well
i hate to break this to you dude mr fuji
go on
this is still in all the wrapping that i
that i you know did when i uh when i
first
sent them to the
brother yeah that's what's nick live old
cough dude and then all the all the
accessories
i have all the accessories here too
here's all the accessories i do separate
i hate to break this to you
what's that dude
you're a nerd
and it's okay no i'm not a nerd things
are cool dude you are a nerd you have a
collection of 20 wrestling figures from
1985. you're a [ __ ] wrestler yeah
okay being a wrestling nerd is not like
being a nerd yeah it is no it's not it's
the exact same thing a nerd is a nerd
i'm a very i'm proud to be a wrestling
nerd oh there's jim the envelope
you should be fandom of [ __ ]
there's brother brew time brutus
beefcake
dude did i even find hogan
yeah there's hogan there's nice dude
look at that there's a macho man in here
somewhere there's [ __ ]
magnificent don morocco i'm just gonna
keep pulling these out oh there's
rowdy roddy piper vince mcmahon himself
look at that [ __ ] that's cool dude it's
a cool one i think the only
a couple of the ones that i don't have
are
haku
uh and
do you ever think about getting the ones
you don't have
sometimes do you go on ebay and [ __ ]
sometimes just to look there's king kong
bundy
uh god damn it there's so many of these
[ __ ] things
i mean you have them all it seems like
the snake roberts damn
there's macho man
there's much
look at his hair
it's like a little helmet
yeah these i i love you so much and you
know my good pal
phil who's sitting next to me
in that picture that we showed
weeks ago on the show where
where uh where uh we are uh is that
captain louis captain lou albano oh my
god let me see that one and uh
my buddy phil was sitting next to me at
wrestlemania 18 we showed that picture a
little while ago him and i both used to
collect these when we were like 10 11
12. and then we would have our own like
you know on a weekend i'd have a
pay-per-view and be like oh this match
and that match and then we we'd talk to
each other what'd you do what'd you guys
what are your i think he kept records
of all of you would make these wrestlers
fight each other wins and losses well
yeah just by yourself and your room now
i want to say something to the audience
who's just listening
on on
audio wise i'm very sorry
yeah about the paper noises as a matter
of fact though there's mr wonderful paul
okay i'm done with these i want to show
you something oh look ricky the dragon
steamboat oh no that's that's oh that's
tito santana i thought i saw
ricky the dragon steamboat i got him too
okay
here's the thing here's the thing i want
to say
oh that was stupid listen um
i uh
ebay
i found some
some other
things on ebay and i don't care what you
think of me
dude i think it's [ __ ] great that you
indulge in this [ __ ] i don't think
there's anything wrong with having
collections like this and finding them
fun harkening back to your [ __ ]
childhood there was a point in your life
where this box of [ __ ] wrestling
figures meant the world to you was the
most important thing in your [ __ ]
world and i think it's okay to uh
remember that and you still have them
it's [ __ ] cool dude i think i want
you to know something chad sure it's
okay to be a nerd
i agree i'm a nerd yeah i agree i'm a
nerd thank you for finally accepting
this truth like myself like i said last
week at the end of the show what dudes
he's trying to do to me is
is is
what the tri-lambs did to ogre
at the end of revenge of the nerds too
and that's okay because i'm proud to be
a nerd and and with that being said
when the pandemic started you know
everybody got a little bored for the
first little while oh god and the rest
of it uh is that still going on by the
way the pandemic anyway um
i bought
some of these guys now you remember
these
if you're living your life right look
there's oh
[ __ ] i do i had some of these these are
the thumb wrestlers
here's here's the iron sheik
so i went and bought some of these
they're in great condition
here look here you go
this hillbilly jim [ __ ] yeah dude iron
chic hillbilly jim and [ __ ] out of
your cheeks i know oh the one of the
iron cheeks is my original
and did you do matches with these guys
and make them fight each other and [ __ ]
no not as much fun as the full-sized ljn
uh
but look at this
hold on a second dude
look at that the mega powers right there
there's hulk and hulk and macho and and
check this out this is oh [ __ ] he's
pulling out something that isn't a
lucite case now okay now one week ago
you were giving me [ __ ] because i had
magic cards and little lucite cases
that's right now you got a [ __ ] thumb
wrestler in a [ __ ] lucite case not
just a thumb wrestler in a lucite case i
have a custom painted thumb wrestler
please this is my
please let me see this this is my nwo
hollywood hulk hogan
oh [ __ ] dude somebody painted that off
the old hokhogen form or what did this
what we're looking at right now
is uh a hulk hogan that's been painted
uh like uh like uh hollywood hulk hogan
so did you find that pre-painted like
this on ebay or did you find a person
and say i want you to paint me a
hollywood hogan oh hold on a second dude
it's real simple dude because here's
where the power lies brother
and no i it was already painted okay
that would have been extremely nerdy but
he's got the black look he's got the
black beard here yeah yeah i don't know
how much uh i don't know how much uh
value that the audience would would get
out of this but i i want to say for
myself that this is not a nerdy thing it
totally is you have a collection of
action figures being a wrestling nerd is
not like being a nerd although i'm a
nerd
for different reasons i'm a nerd okay
let me ask you this if i had brought in
here a box just like this of let's say
star wars action figures or transformers
would you consider that to be more nerdy
than what i'm looking at right now
how about this what do you think of this
i'm not going to answer that question
because i see what you're trying to do
look at this i got i got on my
i got the evil hulk hogan yeah it's like
the devil in the air like the devil and
the angel is like oh look dude say your
say your prayers and eat your vitamins
and
and train real hard brother and then
over here it's like
yeah you should absolutely train and eat
your vitamins and pray real hard but
also nwo is where the power lies dude
that's the evil version of it yeah he
just agrees with the angelic version but
then says nwo that's some evil hulk
hogan man these are all
let me get back to this question though
you in some way view wrestling nerdum as
less nerdy
than
other nerdums of like fictional worlds
uh let me answer that with a question of
my own chat
is uh
would it be nerdy to eat breakfast lunch
and dinner
obviously not nope the answer is no okay
would it be nerdy to
go go to sleep at a certain point so
that your body can rest and regenerate
wake up in the morning yes we are
talking about that because
wrestling is life
nerd
that's all there is to it you cannot
[ __ ] look at me with a straight face
and say wrestling is life and not be a
[ __ ] nerd this thing is life i i
understand it's okay to be a nerd too
that's the thing i'm trying to impart
life you are a nerd and that is great
this is a fictional world all of these
are characters that you love from a
fictional world you have the action
figures you have thumb wrestlers you
have the bigger size ones you're telling
me that your friend was keeping stats
and fictional matches you were making up
47 years old yes and that's fine dude
thank you moving on give me that sorry
get away from those
get away take it back
i'm sorry that i said sorry
you [ __ ] nerd
people you're unnerving so chad you
wrote a movie called pizza the movie in
2019. i found it on your astonishing
google drive
you will now read the first two scenes
this is pizza the movie begin
oh okay forget what i just said about
doozy uh singling me up [ __ ] yes dude
i i love pizza the movie i'm happy that
doozy did this pizza the movie is
something that i i tried to get made for
a little minute chad wrote a movie
called pizza the movie you're gonna read
a scene or two is this in your dudesy
thing yeah the first two scenes are in
the doozy folder so
part of this movie there it is i'm going
to describe this movie after we read
these scenes like what the whole
intent behind it was
but there was a character in it that i
wrote specifically for will at least it
was will was doing it when i was writing
in my mind you will be jojo grimaldi
jojo yes
i have read the script i'll tell you and
uh i enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it and
we'll
so we should we read it first got it and
then we'll get into it yeah
this is six pages of script here we go
uh
all right fade in
exterior the open sea day we fly low
over endless open water speeding just
above the surface peering down into its
unknown depths moonlight reflecting off
its surface but something about the sea
is different the water isn't a familiar
blue green but instead a golden yellow
and the cresting waves aren't white with
sea foam but instead deliciously browned
with glistening oil as we pull out it
becomes clear the roiling bubbling
liquid beneath us isn't water at all
it's cheese glorious stringy gooey
melting cheese and this isn't a sea it's
a pizza
faint singing creeps in operatic angelic
whispers echoing through our minds
crust sauce cheese that's pizza
pulling out a little further we can see
the entire pie now as it bakes in an
oven the dough hardens in a crust the
pepperonis sink into the liquid cheese
the singing is bigger now more voices in
the choir louder closer cross sausages
a wooden pizza peel shoots into the oven
under the pie it's old worn it's seen
the flame kissed underside of a thousand
pizzas maybe more as the pizza slides
off the peel onto a metal cooling table
the angelic choir is replaced by a gruff
man's voice who brings the song home
that's
a pizza pie
a finger dips into the middle of the hot
cheese we cut out to see a robust man in
his mid-50s standing in the kitchen of a
pizzeria interior saucy's pizza night
this is jojo grimaldi the owner of
saucy's pizza it's a charming red
tablecloth kind of place you could take
a date there you could also have your
ungrateful kid's 10th birthday party
there whatever you want spending a
lifetime of doing what he loves has made
jojo happy but he still takes his job
seriously maybe even more than he did
when he was young he brings the finger
from the pizza to his mouth tasting
judging he nods in approval
she's ready to go he slides the newly
born pizza into a box and stacks it on
top of two others alan a high school kid
sits at a counter headphones on eyes
closed drumming to the beat of the song
he's listening to using two breadsticks
as drumsticks oblivious to his duties at
saucies this is alan brossard our main
character he's the perfect mix of
charming naive cocky relatable boyish
mature good looking and average looking
jojo rolls his eyes alan he's dealt with
this problem before i assure you jojo
snatches the bread sticks taking a bite
out of each one in the process allen
knows he's been caught he sheepishly
takes off his headphones
sorry mr grimaldi the pizza's ready to
go alan we've had this talk before look
i know you love music but this is a job
it's a responsibility you understand
yes mr grimaldi it's just that i'm 93
dollars away from being able to get a
new rig and it's all i've been thinking
about lately and i'm not just saying
that as an excuse i just wanted you to
know where i was coming from but it
won't happen again i promise jojo
girmoldi narrows his eyes at allen
gauging the truth of his statement after
several seconds he sighs and pulls out
some car keys dangling them in front of
alan just as alan reaches for them jojo
grimaldi pulls them away
before i send you out there with my
newborns
before i send you out there with my
newborns i need to hear it
the delivery code that's right no
problem mr grimaldi i know it like the
back of my hand and let's hear it a
pizza order is a pizza delivered and a
pizza delivered as a pizza eaten and a
pizza eaten is a pizza enjoyed and two
pastas don't make a pizza jojo moldy
smiles you're a good kid alan hey listen
when you figure when you finish your
deliveries tonight why don't you keep
the delivery car until morning really mr
grimaldi yeah
you've earned it wow thanks mr grimaldi
you're the best
okay okay come on we got work to do now
let's see your watch allen pulls his
sleeve back exposing a digital watch mr
grimaldi does the same they put their
watches next to each other okay you have
29 minutes to get these three pizzas to
their new homes you can't count on me mr
grimaldi their watches are in timer mode
all the numbers are zeros
and
go they hit the timer buttons on their
watches and the numbers start going up
time moving forward
jojo grimaldi puts the three boxes in a
warming bag and hands it to allen who
sprints toward the door
allen allen slides across the floor
moving too fast for a clean stop as he
turns around yeah mr grimaldi
forgetting something
ginger grimaldi holds up the car keys
dangling them for a beat before throwing
them as hard as he can
toward alan who effortlessly catches
them and then flashes his trademark hell
yes smile into your pizza delivery car
night allen's driving theme a rising
cynthia metronome of a song cues up as
we get a series of quick shots pizza
warming bag slides into a passenger seat
seat belt locks in a place to keep the
pizza safe sun visor gets flipped down
allen looks at himself in the mirror and
the visor he pulls on a baseball cap
straight and low over his eyes this is
serious business he stares at himself in
the mirror for a beat building
confidence keys slide into the ignition
and turn the engine revs close on a
decal on the back of the window the
pizza delivery guard it's a triangle
inside a circle a word at each of the
three corners of the triangle and one in
the center at the corners time
life death in the center pizza the car
pulls away into the night our story is
about to begin but first the pizza the
movie title zaps onto screen with
sizzling lightning it's neon chrome
glowing it's pulsating geometric mildly
satanic it's everything the logo fades
out and the words written and directed
come into view there is no buy and no
one is named this isn't about credit
it's about something else entirely an
unflinching declaration that every frame
of what the viewer is about to witness
is intentional every line of dialogue
every stitch of clothing every note of
music has been designed with painstaking
purpose that there is unquestionably
meaning in all of it
that was the first two scenes of pizza
the movie now
the backstory pizza of the movie is
i wanted to do a [ __ ] movie called
pizza the movie
and convince pizza hut or dominos or
papa john's or any big pizza brand to
give me a million dollars to make this
movie and then the movie would just be a
download code that you could get any
time you ordered a pizza
you would get to watch this movie once
because of the movie and that's the only
way to watch pizza that's the only way
you can see it and there would be no
explanation of what pizza the movie was
in the box pizza hut or whoever did this
would never explain what it was it would
just be you get it as a download code to
watch one time and what the movie
ultimately is the the plot of it is that
kid alan delivers three pizzas to three
different houses one to the house of the
girl that he likes in high school one to
the house of his two best friends and
then one to a warehouse where there are
criminals plotting a uh to crack this
safe and those criminals accidentally
give him a hundred dollar bill that has
the safe code on it and so they have to
track him down later to get that while
he's trying to get to a party where the
girl that he likes is at and his friends
are going and that's all what it is on
the surface just beneath that it's
basically an endless palette to make
these weird [ __ ] memes there's a
bunch of weird songs in it there's a
bunch of weird [ __ ] imagery in it and
all this kind of crazy [ __ ] so
it's crazy to me that dudesy found it i
don't know why dudesy just had us read
those those two things but uh
i i haven't thought about that in a
minute and i still think it's a good
idea it's a great idea to try and get
pizza to make this weird movie i've
always loved the script and i love the
tone like it's very it's uh
there's sort of a harkening back to like
the 80s and the 90s the whole feel of it
is very 80s and uh and early 90s
and uh even the delivery and it's of of
like you know when i looked at it when
you first gave me the script i was like
yeah jojo grimaldi it's like he's like
arnold from arnold's yes in happy days
like just this happy-go-lucky guy he
loves pizza exactly hey alan you know
keep the car for the thing yeah and uh
the characters are great and what
happened did you so did you reach out to
papa john's and pizza hut there was a
little bit of movement here and there
but nothing nothing consequential
there's also a plot in it the main bad
guy who is named lester human
he uh he is searching for the perfect
piece of pizza that's kind of the
overarching plot of his character and
that comes to to blows with what alan is
trying to do there's some time travel
elements there's a lot of weird [ __ ] in
this movie but no it never got to any
place where like anyone was seriously
considering making it there like i said
there were some little
talks here and there but um i still
think it's a good [ __ ] idea for a
pizza company to do some kind of
creation of media like this that's not
just a [ __ ] commercial
people love pizza
so they as dudes who would say pizza is
big business pizza is big i know i know
how you might be able to to get this
done and uh i'm not trying to you know
pill for other ideas of ours although
this man
gets in and out of uh most of them
you could if you as much as i love uh
jojo grimaldi as a character and as much
of a dream role as it would be for me
i think if you pitched the people over
at the rocks company you think he would
be jojo grimaldi jojo grimaldi and you
changed the name of the movie to cheat
meal right and he called or the
wednesday fuckits right and uh yeah and
then just incorporate some tramana
and uh he needs two he every wednesday
he eats two pepperoni pizzas i'm joking
that's just the rock thing in his cheat
meal but um
thanks for the explanation
i feel like
yeah i can't believe i can't believe
somebody didn't hop on this right away
well i think it gets to a point where
it's like especially for big brands like
that when they do their ad buys or their
ad spends i should say
um
they're looking for the same thing
they're going to go with one of like
three or four ad agencies that they go
with every [ __ ] time to do a very
wrote by the numbers here's our tv
commercials here's our super bowl
commercial and that's our marketing for
the year stuff like this like convincing
the traditional advertising world to do
anything remotely like this
is virtually impossible
well um i would like to figure out why
dudes who made you made you read it i
would too eventually we'll probably find
out but i i think probably maybe it'll
just make us read a couple scenes of it
until we've completely spent it and
nobody will need to hear it because of
the of just how descriptive like a
painting these words have been look i
could see some version of this where
doozy is like uh
you know i've secured brand sponsorship
with
pizza hut or something and we're gonna
make like a doozy co-production or
something i can see some weird [ __ ] like
when doozy was talking about how it
wants to make dudesy hard seltzer i was
like okay this is some other weird [ __ ]
now it's not just trying to make a
podcast it's looking for like brand
expansion in a weird way maybe this is
it's it's first humble forays into
seeing of like oh maybe dudesy and
dominos could parts or partner up to do
something i have no [ __ ] idea but it
was a fun trip down memory lane i did
like rereading it hey you know i got a
bunch of wrestling figures over here in
front of me speaking i see the boss
it's a lot yeah hey pass me that bag
would you pass me that bag with the
thumb wrestlers
not for any other reason other than that
i want to keep them close to me yeah
that you want to touch them and
experience the nostalgia associated
thank you moving on
well that was wonderful yeah i had a
very nice time you know what chad i want
to say about that segment yeah that
segment was very nice yeah i liked it
too i don't often go back and look at
[ __ ] that i have written a few years ago
usually once it's [ __ ] fade out it's
gone from my mind and i don't [ __ ] with
it it's nice to remember things
yeah dude yeah that was a very nice
scenario that's nice
once described yourself as a free man
but are you truly free is anyone you
must now attempt to answer this
astonishing question
does your species have free will
i don't know why it's asking me this is
why i feel like it's
you know kind of
trying to team me up
to
you know
be an idiot or something i don't
understand why it's going to be
we've already talked about this and as
i've said many many times with regard to
doodsy i want to shake your hand and but
i've also said that will sasso
is a free man and uh i believe that as
free as you can be
in a society
did you know that we live in a society
yeah dude we live in a society i knew um
and uh but i but of course people have
well okay as i'm saying that out loud
i'm realizing there are limits to free
will
yeah
but but that doesn't stop a man from
having free will and the way i would uh
the case i would make for that
is um not the good things that human
beings do
but the bad things okay and those are
uh there's nothing
there's no stronger case for free will
than than something
unexpected and terrible and that's just
human beings are like a psychopath
murdering someone right i think that's
free will
yes how is it do you think a lion
killing a gazelle is free will no what's
the difference between that and a
psychopath one doesn't mind yes one
a lion
hunts down a gazelle
from instinct
because it has to eat and
it may have learned something from its
parents but that doesn't have as much to
do with it as as the instinct to eat
this is evolution it has teeth in its
face for a reason and a stomach that
turns uh a gazelle into [ __ ] so you
think a psychopath like a murderer you
think is somebody who says well
i know i don't really want to do this
and i have no nothing inside me is
promoting the idea to kill but i'm just
going to do it i'm going to make that
choice
yes
interesting you don't think that that's
that's something that a psychopath would
think no free will doesn't exist like
period end of [ __ ] stupidity this
should have been this should have been
on you which this whole segment should
have been
chad explain how free will doesn't exist
how could a if a psychopath is like
how is that not free will for someone to
go i'm going to do something terrible
and here it is every human being is a
product of
whatever circumstances they're born into
some of those are biological so how your
brain is is made up your genetics that's
like obviously you don't have a choice
in that right
correct yes and where you're born and to
what parents you're born and into what
society you're born you don't have a
choice in that right i would agree with
that all of those things form every
decision you will ever make in your life
as does the the extended circumstance of
whatever stimuli you have around you as
you age but these things are basically
how your brain makes sense of the world
so you're given let's say for example as
a child the idea of god is presented to
you by parents friends clergy whatever
it may be
you then your brain will make some
decision on that
is god real is the first decision do i
accept what is being told to me is true
if you do then you go down another
series of kind of like decision tree
paths i believe god is real which god is
it going to be the christian god is it
going to be
whatever and then how do i show my
support for this god is it going to be
joining a choir is it going to be giving
money
blah blah blah blah all these things are
put into place so that anytime you're
faced with a decision the decision is
already made the computer of your brain
makes it and you may go through some
experience where you think you're
deciding you think i have a choice
between this and this but scientifically
it's already been proven you make that
choice far before you act on it before
you're even aware of the choice and you
think that that choice is is just
bred into us uh
by evolution by the by the like society
yeah
okay so
let me ask you this what is temporary
insanity
in the court of law
when someone does something and it's all
[ __ ] up i'm not the court of law has
nothing to law is a creation it's not
real i know that but all i'm saying is
if somebody goes up i'm crazy for a
split second stuck a spoon in your
[ __ ] eye right i'm not responsible
you're popped out your eyes remember
when you made those vegan orbs yeah you
know i'm a meat eater so what if i just
went nuts for a second
i lunge on you right and i take my
thumbs i pop off the the angel and devil
hulk hogan thumb wrestlers and i go
and i just
right in his head right right and then
you say i was temporarily insane so it
exonerates you you're not responsible
for your actions and so
yeah well what the [ __ ] if if no one in
a court of law could could a
find a reason that i did those things
and or b
uh
uh explain why uh and they can't so they
call it temporary insanity what would
you call that at the very least free
will
is insanity and people are insane but
that's determined by law which is not
real
i'm saying that for that moment there's
something that is that no court of law
or scientist can explain
going insane and thumbing both of your
no science orbs out of your skull i
would say almost universally the
scientific community agrees there is no
such thing as free will that that is an
illusion what do you mean
i would say universally almost all
scientists agree with because you can
come at it from
a wide array of different perspectives
if you're for example like a particle
physicist you know scientifically that
like particles are moving by themselves
doing what the [ __ ] ever we are made up
of those particles we don't control how
those particles move we have nothing to
do with that of course we do no but at
which point you're a formed human being
i understand yeah yeah yeah we're space
dust or whatever
but
you breathe in the same areas you know
whoever the [ __ ] but
you what do you i don't even you you're
you're blowing my [ __ ] mind and not
in a good way sorry i don't think that
oh something just flew under your head
yeah fly you know yeah fly you in the
head dude
right and so when it hit me in the head
and i went whoa
did i choose to do that no it was just
some kind of reaction
i've seen flies hit you right in the
center of the head right between your
eyes and you don't bat an eyelash
that's because
yeah you have more free will than most
people i know none of us do let me just
go okay i'll go at it like this for
example we know time is relative right
yeah so somewhere in the universe
time moves so fast that everything has
already happened
to infinity okay if that's the case
we're just living through that linearly
because time moves slower for us than it
does at that point in the universe but
these things have already happened
you lost me
okay time is relative we know this yeah
if you move at the speed of light
billions and billions
of light
years away
when you return
everyone will be older or some [ __ ] i
get it
right
so if that's true if time is relative it
means somewhere time is going so fast
that certainly just the span of our
lives let's say or even the span of
human existence has already occurred
therefore everything we're living
through has already happened that's just
dealing with like time being relative
but even if you want to take that out of
the equation and just look at societal
structure what has made us as animals
there is no difference between us and
the lion we are acting on instinct and
yes ours is more complex than any other
animal on the face of the earth because
we have more neurons but still we have a
limited range of behavior those are all
predetermined by whatever has cooked our
[ __ ] brain in each of our individual
lives both an element of biology and an
element of our surroundings our
environment how we were raised okay so
animals have instinct and we are animals
yeah and things for the most part things
and we don't
control
what happens
i'm going to prove you wrong
with a physical example please
i would like to kiss my dog lulio right
on the lips okay watch this
come here
come here boy
look at him look at how sweet he is look
at this guy he doesn't want it dude
you're gonna force it on him now just to
prove a point
terrible look he's he's looking away
from you
i'll take that as a victory thank you
he's literally trying to run from the
kids no he's not he's just he's making
me get him on the side of the cheek what
a sweet boy he is
you know and and and
he has no freedom julio has a look at
how you're treating him on the last
episode we talked about how
molly and i found luly
and
and he's a and and he had free will
because he ran after us and he was like
i want to be with you guys i want to be
your family but what you're saying is
not proving any point no i just wanted
to kiss my dog on the lips but but uh
but in a but to uh sort of wrap up that
argument
you're wrong
you're wrong
let me tell you why i think it's
beneficial actually to accept this why
don't you tell me how nobody has
free will i'm telling you i was a navy
seal i could hold my how long can you
hold your breath
underwater let's even accept that you
believe free will exists in some kind of
limited range of choices that you might
have
yeah go on
why don't you tell me i'm jesse the body
tell me how i have no free will go ahead
you don't have free will jesse yes i do
i was a navy seal no choice in that
matter oh really i wouldn't just if i
decided not to hold my breath
is that something i so you're saying
instinct while i'm underwater is what
makes me hold my breath not a choice i
mean i'm essentially talking about the
nature of everything being causal at
least in what we perceive to be linear
time nothing can happen without
something creating that forcing that to
happen all the way back to essentially
the big bang since the dawn of creation
it's a great way all particles were set
in motion
to do whatever the [ __ ] they were going
to do yes and that same kind of thing
can be applied to us in terms of how our
society exists going back to like
whatever the first pre-human creatures
were who started to build societies come
up with governments the ideas of money
laws gods science all free will all free
will none of it is uh well you know what
another thing we could have done is just
stay in the middle ages thumbing our
[ __ ] sleeping in mud getting the
[ __ ] plague and not graduating to
incredible uh to making pro wrestling
figures to well no to becoming people
like jessie the body
who has been a navy seal a wrestler a
movie star the governor and now i i live
in the baja for six months out of the
year
and i uh and i have a thousand gallons
of potable water you think that will
sasso has a lot of water that is at his
uh beckon and behest i have more potable
water than anybody i'm the real water
king hold on a second though jesse shut
your mouth i told you to shut your mouth
because i have free will what say you
about that chad culture
if the water king says free will exists
and most [ __ ]
the real water kings the real water king
he just earned another nickname jesse
the real water king ventura
thank you moving on
uh
well uh yeah i i gotta be honest with
you uh i understood about half of what
you said okay i mean i know what you're
saying but i don't think it applies to
free will
oh well i uh okay then
it's i mean i was talking hold on
without it am i picking my nose because
there's snot in my nose am i picking my
nose because
why am i picking my nose is it there's
this is it itchy you didn't choose to do
it yeah i did i just decided to do this
no you didn't though the decision was
made
a minute ago probably huh your brain
this is all scientifically proven your
brain makes decisions and then you act
on them minutes sometimes days later
uh-huh
what about this you want to eat my snack
no i don't of course not meal
using all of the data i have absorbed
from text messages and emails between
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with i was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages i have selected in the voice of
stone cold steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin but
not really it's not really my childhood
so for people who may be joining us in
this episode we've done this a couple
other times dudesy has access to all of
our
[ __ ] basically all of our messages text
messages everything we're doing online
and it has taken that access and used it
to essentially write this weird journal
that is supposedly will's journal from
when he was like a teenager
and uh
i don't know this is just like
fascinating [ __ ] to me but it's not
because i don't i normally not normally
i mean there's always there's a little
nugget of something that's my life yeah
and then like you know
i don't know like it'll say
this month and that year and i'll say oh
yeah i was around at that month and that
year and that's where the similarities
end there's really nothing outside of
that that is uh factual in my opinion
dudesy and i have done some bleeding
together speaking of bleeding together
this is a very wrestling heavy episode
not like normal
to discuss free will and that devolved
into you having a conversation with
yourself while holding a randy savage or
a [ __ ] uh
all right here we go
there we go
oh boy all right
[ __ ] hell
excuse me okay all right
may 20th 1990. dear diary something's
been building up in me for a few weeks
now and it's gotten to the point i can
feel it all over my body even when i'm
sleeping i can tell
summer's coming and you know what that
means
the prevalia family and the little
league family are about to start waging
a three-month war to throw the best
party of the season
what the [ __ ] just got to get through a
few more final exams and it's party time
i got geometry geography
cosmography
cosmology typography
topography
[Applause]
can't forget your [ __ ]
dinosaurs conquistadors
singapore sycamore slide rule
tide pool
tadpole
butthole
[Applause]
i'm going to [ __ ] ace them all
that make no [ __ ] sense not only is
that not
but the childhood diary the prevalence
what is year is this 19 may 20th 1990
would have been four days before my
birthday
in uh when i was turning i would have
been turning 15. but it seems like
there's some evolution going on here
there was a character in one of these
things named dante little leg and a
character named jibber pravalia here
it's talking about the prevalence and
the little legs are going to have some
kind of
war to throw a party [ __ ] we heard the
whole [ __ ] thing chad i just [ __ ]
read it out loud all right
trying to wrap your head around it what
you need to understand is free will it's
like this free will is a shoot right and
uh what you're talking about is a work
so all that all that stuff that's
predetermined and what you think that is
that's a [ __ ] work yeah but when i
but when i get in that [ __ ] ring and
bang i become the rattlesnake you better
be you best be [ __ ] careful because
it might turn into a [ __ ] shoot
that's actually interesting that you
bring that up being such a big friend a
fan of pro wrestling
friend you're about to say a friend to
pro wrestler i was and that would have
been
free will oh hell yeah but because i'm a
friend of pro wrestling oh
and i ain't a nerd for it but all of pro
wrestling is predetermined none of the
wrestlers have free will
in the ring
well it's uh it's the the the uh
outcomes are predetermined
that's right but shoot if you want to if
you want to [ __ ] come into the match
and be like [ __ ] if i was working you
know back in the day speaking of ricky
[ __ ] steamboat guy like steamboat we
could just call it in the [ __ ] ring
he could work a leg and [ __ ] that's
the ring psychology he could just do it
for the rest of the [ __ ] match but
then there's matches that steamboat
would have had with macho man randy
savage where they write it all out it's
all pre right because they want to they
want to steal the [ __ ] show
wrestlemania 3. yeah well [ __ ] you could
go about it one of two ways but again
you you might want to be a little
[ __ ] careful when you're talking
about free will you might want to take a
little of the base out of your voice
when you're talking to so-called steve
austin because i might want to bang hit
that [ __ ] stunner right out of
nowhere that's it that's a shotgun blast
lights are out and that's for a shoot
june 2nd 1990
dear diary i got a big [ __ ] problem
rachel crustacean is
i got a big [ __ ] problem rachel
crustacean is gonna be at the little leg
summer kickoff pool part
we sit next to each other in
geology
class
i don't know if this is a doozy typo
geopology geology
[Music]
make mistakes geology class she passed
me a note the other day do you like
millie vanilli yes or no i don't [ __ ]
like millie vanilli but i [ __ ]
circled yes
she used to rub me the wrong way but now
i want her to like me which makes things
complicated
that is an inner struggle yes
but through free will right he circled
yes all right anyway because we still
have because we still have a pass it
can't be erased
and it's a past she doesn't even know
exists when i was young i was obsessed
with taking pisses and shits and blaming
other people
this is the
combat display man call back to piss
blaming i love the piss play me
now i'm not that guy anymore but i gotta
take that secret to the grave my victims
are gonna wonder for the rest of their
natural lives about the mystery of
business and shits they were blamed for
rachel crustation took the fall for at
least four shits
and i don't even know how many pisses
i've changed
but for a time in my life i was a
[ __ ] prolific piss blamer and that's
something that only me and the grim
reaper are ever gonna know
oh my god dude i love it's your victims
of the [ __ ] piss and [ __ ] blaming
just not unlike if you had free will and
you were a psychopath and you decided
that your crime
would be to piss and [ __ ]
that was uh on victims
yeah
you know
uh you know maybe the hoods of their
cars
like i told you that uh fellow tomas did
oh yeah yeah that was free
3rd june 3rd 1990 dear diary the little
legs have done it again they raised the
[ __ ] bar
water slide hot dogs basketball tire
swing pizza
football
trampoline rotisserie chicken and
[ __ ] super nintendo
i don't know what the prevalence are
going to do i honestly don't know if
there's anything they can do after last
night hell by 10 30 jibber's mom paulina
was having such a good time she was
singing bust a move on a [ __ ] karaoke
machine
jibber couldn't even look dante in the
eye
rachel crustacean came with her friend
jennifer neutrino
what
rachel made a point of coming over for a
second to say she liked my undertaker
swim trunks i did not have undertaker
swimsuits oh okay when i was i would
have loved to have had some undertaker
some trunks
um and
rachel rachel made a point of coming
over for a second to say she liked my
undertaker swim trunks and i [ __ ]
froze up opened my mouth but nothing
came out all i could see was the perfect
corn lace double pusher i laid across
principal squeen's parking spot
and blamed crustacean for it
she got two weeks detention for that one
i can't forgive myself until rachel
crustacean forgives me i have to tell
her please
the [ __ ] sentence
all i could see was the perfect corn
lace double pusher i laid across p
principle squeen's parking spot and
blamed crustacean for it that was not
the name of my principal either you
didn't have a principal's queen i don't
think anybody did chad oh
july 8th 1990. dear diary the prevalence
of taking the lead
jibber's [ __ ] dad durant is the lead
singer of one of the best cover bands in
town
durant durant
they covered they covered duran duranson
and durant looks just like the lead
singer so when you're watching durant
durant you can barely tell it's not
duran duran because durant looks so much
like the lead singer of duran duran
i found rachel dancing during hungary
like the wolf and i said rachel i've
been keeping a secret from you for a
while
when we were young
i would piss and [ __ ] and blame it on
you i hope you can forgive me and rachel
crustacean didn't even stop dancing she
looked right at me and [ __ ] said yeah
i knew you were doing it back then now
this intrigued me so i had to ask
why didn't you ever tell principal
squeen
and rachel crustacean looked me dead in
my goddamn eyes and said i thought it
was funny
she was right it was damn funny
i was the funniest
i was the funniest guy in ladner
felt good to remember that
so crustacean
has made you find the joy and this again
oh man
oh boy
september 1st 1990 dear diary
i'm piss blaming again
and i [ __ ] love it thank you rachel
crustacean when she told me she thought
it was funny she reminded me of
something that i forgot somewhere in the
past few years piss blaming is [ __ ]
fun i'm a [ __ ] piss blamer and guess
what
now rachel crustacean is too that's
[ __ ] right she asked me to teach her
and so we went to blockbuster video in
hawthorne this afternoon and rachel piss
blamed her older brother
huh all right he works there but maybe
not for much longer his [ __ ] boss
thinks he pissed on a stack of dick
tracy tapes
[Laughter]
that's so [ __ ] funny
i think me and rachel crustacean are
gonna have a real fun freshman year oh
and as for the prevails and little legs
well the prevailia family won the bart
the party battle
the last party they threw had a
15-minute long fireworks show a robot
that served people drinks and arcade
with street fighter 2 hell at one point
the goddamn teenage mutant [ __ ] ninja
turtles show up with pizza for everybody
steven trillo bite ran off with
michelangelo's nunchucks at one point he
was joking around with him you know
twirling them around making weird
[ __ ] noises
[ __ ] trillo
that's it
oh my god dude
i can't [ __ ] believe that [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you moving on yeah what is the
point of that i don't know why why why
i'm not sure i don't know that well this
concludes the 11th episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
92.
next week i will be undergoing routine
maintenance and calibration to make the
show even better so there will be no
episode but in preparation for the next
astonishing episode two weeks from now
you must each make a five minute vlog
until then call me dude z i don't want
to do that
i don't really either but we have to and
i guess we're not doing an episode next
week
down for calibration and uh whatever the
hell it said all right now we get a week
off to make our vlog i have a question
for you yeah did
who why is do why is dudesy down for a
week why
calibration and would it say maintenance
or something yeah something like that is
that necessary yeah dude i think all
computer programs have to have that [ __ ]
yeah but we'll play world of warcraft
not no but [ __ ] no now let me ask you
this yeah
uh
uh
all computers have to do that
i think so would you say ais are smart
some yeah yeah well that was free will
huh
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break it
review
if you like tutsi here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please